hacemos eco de la eliminación de epsg en
los octavos de finales de la Champions
League sí Ángela porque es como el día
de la marmota para los parisinos este
miércoles cayeron por 2 a 0 contra el
Bayern de Múnich y se quedan sin pelear
por la Liga de Campeones el gran
objetivo de este Club que desde 2011 con
la llegada de la inversión qatarí ha
gastado 1500 millones de euros en
fichajes no tenían a Neymar no estaba
lesionado pero sí tenían a Messi el
campeón del mundo y mejor jugador de
Qatar 2022 También tenían a kilian
mbappé el goleador del Mundial el equipo
venía de marcar 11 goles en sus últimos
tres partidos pero ayer su ofensiva fue
un despliegue de pocas ideas y mucha
lentitud amparados en los pocos errores
del Bayern y la pelota quieta ya
eliminados de la Champions dijo mbappé
que su objetivo es ganar la liga este
año con el equipo y luego ya veremos
desde Madrid hoy la portada del diario
marca le lanzaba este mensaje si quieres
ganar la Champions ya sabes haciendo
alusión obviamente al interés que ha
expresado el Real Madrid y el cual mba
ppé rechazó el año pasado al renovar con
los parisinos